nous avons rappelé
il y environ quatre ans que la caisse
des monuments historiques avait décidé
de classer quimper ville d'art et ainsi
nous appartenons à une élite de villes
françaises qui ont été sélectionnés à
cette époque nous sommes seize réunis et
ensemble par une chaîne d'amitié et nous
essayons de cette façon à faire de la
propagande au point de vue de la visite
des monuments historiques
ces visites santé organisé d'une façon
extrêmement sérieuse par les caisses des
monuments historiques
nous faisons passer chaque printemps un
examen à plusieurs étudiants qui ont des
connaissances approfondies sur la région
une sélection est opérée les trois
premiers leurs candidats sont chargés de
faire des visites commentées au cours de
la période d'été qui commence le 5
juillet fini le 15 septembre
et voici justement l'un d'eux ce guide
ou plutôt l'une de ces guides et les
charmants qui voyez vous vous êtes
mademoiselle odile prioul et vous êtes
étudiant survie monsieur je suis
étudiante en lettres modernes et je
termine
année qui vient en lettres et 9 ans
d'histoire et pourquoi vous
intéressez-vous à ces visites viens j'ai
toujours habité quimper et j'aime
beaucoup les
l'ancien et surtout l'histoire qui s'y
rapportent enfin les raisons que vous
avez devant vous sondez maison du xvème
siècle d'au moins deux styles xvème
siècle parce que l on était très souvent
restaurer surtout au xviiie siècle et
celle ci qui est très particulière et
amusante était une taverne où toute la
jeunesse noble et notables de la ville
et même les ecclésiastiques
ça va peut-être temps en temps pour
boire et comme si la chute est pas mal
souvent le guet rétablissez l'ordre
alors les sculptures que l'ouvrier de
chaque côté de la porte sont des
représentants d'eads et est hilare de
buveurs joyeux et vous voyez même un qui
tient un verre là et c'est même une
famille vous trouvez devant la partie
xiiie siècle de la cathédrale c'est à
dire le coeur parce que la cathédrale a
été construit en trois fois le coeur qui
est du xiiie siècle le la nef et les
tours du 15e et les flèches du 19e
siècle et malgré de ces différentes
époques où elle forme un ensemble tout à
fait cohérent et tout à fait élégant et
les vitraux du basson dans l'ensemble
modern et parce qu'ils ont été détruit à
la révolution par les révolutionnaires
quand jeté des cailloux dedans et
peut-être parfois part à cause de la
négligence des chanoines qui n'ont pas
toujours fait ce qu'il devait faire
ce duo fera par contre sont dans
l'ensemble
authentique et date du 15ème siècle ils
ont d'ailleurs été fait à quimper où il
existait une école de maître verrier
très importante qui avait trouvé de très
jolis les couleurs dans les pourpres les
dorés et les bleus nous est cette visite
a lieu combien de fois par jour et bien
elle a lieu le matin à 10 heures 30 et
l'après-midi à cinq heures pendant
quelques périodes pendant toute la
période de l'été mais moi j'assure la
visite du 1er août au 8 septembre
et dire combien d'années que vous faites
très bien ça c'est la quatrième année
pas de lassitude non non vous voyez je
reviens je reviens toujours et ça
m'intéresse vraiment beaucoup